>> Marisa Bellack:
Hi there everyone.
Look comfy on those
bean bag chairs.
Hello, I'm Marisa
Bellack, I'm an editor
at the Washington Post,
a charter sponsor of
the book festival.
And I'm pleased to
introduce Meg Medina.
Author of books for children,
pre-teens and young adults
that feature strong
Latina characters grappling
with questions of culture
and identity and facing some
of the central challenges
of our time.
Meg touches on family separation
in her book Tia Isa Wants a Car
which received the 2012 Ezra
Jack Keats New Writer Award.
She deals with migration in
her young adult novel The Girl
Who Could Silence the Wind.
She writes about bullying
in Yaqui Delgado Wants
to Kick Your Ass.
Which was banned from
some school libraries and
yet won the American Library
Associations top honor
for Latino Children
and Young Authors.
Although she was named
Margret Rose after the sister
of Queen Elizabeth, Meg is the
daughter of Cuban immigrants.
She was born in Virginia
and raised in Queens.
She's a founding member
of We Need Diverse Books.
And regularly notes the
depressing statistics that less
than 3% of children's books
are by or about Latinos.
I imagine she may speak
about that some here today.
Her newest book is Merci
Suarez Changes Gears.
It's a story she says
about how to say goodbye
to the important things in life.
The book actually isn't
out until September 11th
but I understand there are
copies available at the festival
and Meg is scheduled
for a signing session
from five to six this evening.
Before we dive into our
discussion I'm suppose
to mention that the Library
of Congress has been
the festivals host
since the festival
began 18 years ago.
I want to thank festival
co-chairman David Rubenstein
and the many sponsors who
made this event possible.
You can support the
festival with a donation,
there's information
in your program.
Please note too that there
will be time for questions
after Meg's remarks and anyone
who asks a question
will be filmed
for the library's archives.
Now please help me
welcome Meg Medina.
[ Applause ]
>> Meg Medina: Thank
you so much.
Buenas tardes, good afternoon
everybody, thanks for coming
out tonight and this afternoon
and you're right you can't
see anybody from up here.
So you're all invisible except
for these really comfortable
kids on the bean bag chairs
and next year can you please
ask them to put a bean bag chair
up here for me because that
would be kind of fun to be able
to talk with you from there.
So I am here, this
is me and my Bitmoji.
I discovered bitmojis
like a year ago
and now I'm unstoppable, I
have a bitmoji for everything.
And this is Meg bitmoji who's
going to be our concierge today.
And I'm here to talk about
Merci Suarez Changes Gears
and you notice that it's a girl
on a bike and we do change gears
on a bike and it
becomes harder to pedal.
But we change gears over
the course of our life
and that's sort of
the idea of that book.
That book did not start as a
novel, it started like this.
I was asked to write a
story for an anthology,
which is a collection of
stories called Flying Lessons
and Other Stories.
And it had some really
great authors,
some of my favorites were
in there like Jackie Woodson
and Kwamer Alexander and Matt
de la Pena and others and so
when they asked me to
write a story they said,
Meg we want a story
the only thing you have
to do is make sure that the
character is Latina like you.
You can tell us any story
that you want to tell us.
And I said I can?
And all of us did, here's
some of us at ALA one year.
So I was thinking about it and
I thought back, I had a memory
of a time when I was
playing with my best friend.
When I was in elementary
school and my best friend
in elementary school
I think you know her.
Her name is Raquel,
but you know her
as RJ Palacio who wrote Wonder.
And so we lived like a block
and a half away from each other
and Raquel is from Colombia
and my family was from Cuba.
And so our mothers could
talk to each other in Espanol
and we were good friends and
one day Raquel and I were
in the back of her house
and the ambulance came.
And the police came and all
these adults were standing
around and not letting us look
and we were like,
what happened right?
And so sadly what had happened
is that there was a gentleman
who lived in her building by
himself, an older gentleman
and he had passed away, he
had died and no one knew.
And so we as little kids were
like oh my gosh we've been
in this building with
a dead body for days
and we were all freaked
out about this.
But over time, over the years
I've thought about that man
and his living alone and
the way that he passed away
and it was just a story that
just always stuck with me.
So when I was writing
Soul Painting, the story,
I started with a dead body.
That's found in the
condominium in Florida
where Merci Suarez lives.
And that morning her father, who
owns Soul Painting Inc arrives
to pick her up, her
and her brother Roli.
And they're going to spend
the day painting the gym
at their new school in
exchange for tuition reduction.
And of course her father
notices this is apartment
with a person who died etcetera.
And the story's really
about what it's
like to be the scholarship kid
in a school where everybody sort
of has more money than you.
And it's a story about what that
looks like, what that feels like
and what it's like for a kid
to see their family
making sacrifices for them.
Okay it was a great
story, I loved it,
the book did really well, I
even did the recording of it
in my own voice which was
really fun and a little scary.
But when I was finished I
thought I was not really
finished because here's
what happens to writers.
The character gets in your
brain, it's like a worm.
And then I'd be walking
around going,
I wonder who else Merci
lived with in Florida.
I wonder how it really went for
her at Seaward Pines Academy.
I wonder who the pain in
the neck is in her class.
I wonder does she have
primos and tias and tios,
like what's the whole shebang.
And so my editor Kate who's
this woman in the picture,
we were together one day
and I was explaining to her
that I couldn't get Merci
and Roli and Poppi and Momi
out of my head and
she said that's
because you're not
finished with the story.
You have to keep writing.
So I did and I decided
okay I'm going
to turn this story into a novel.
And that's the story that is
now Merci Suarez Changes Gears.
Here's the thing, that's what
it looked like as a story
and this is the cover now.
But here's the thing, turning
a story into a novel is
like turning a fish
into a mango.
So the fish and the mango are
both colorful, they're the same.
The fish and the mango
you could say are kind
of tropical, that's the same.
If you want to be really scary
you could say you could eat both
of those things, yes that's true
but they're nothing the same.
And that's the thing
about writing a novel.
That a story is just like a tiny
little piece of someone's life
but a novel is the whole thing.
So I had to rethink
this whole story.
And I decided that I was
going to think about family
because that's what I
normally write about.
So I don't know what your
family is like, but I'm going
to tell you about my familia.
When I think family,
it was not me
and mommy and my sister Lydia.
When I say family I
mean it in a big way.
With my aunts and my
uncles and my grandmother,
I'm the kid in the yellow dress.
And the ladies is my aunt,
my mother, my grandmother
and my other aunt, [foreign
word] and [foreign word].
And over here looking
very miserable on the day
of my holy communion is
me with [foreign word]
and [foreign word], [foreign
word] is this one on this side.
She was very interesting she
use to watch lucha libre,
which is mass Mexican
wrestling on TV.
And she would always be
my after school babysitter
and tell me crazy
kinds of scary stories
like when the hurricane wiped
out her village etcetera.
And [foreign word]
was my fathers mother
and she was the scary abuela,
do you have scary abuelas,
grandma sometimes, very strict?
Who makes you eat radishes
and your salad and they insist
that you wash your hands and you
have to be a little more formal
than you normally are, that
was abuela [foreign word]
and she was also a seamstress,
that's a person who
sews clothes.
She worked in Manhattan
and every year
on my birthday abuela
[foreign word] would show
up with bags filled with my
entire wardrobe for the year.
Which was great because
my mother worked
in a factory she could not
afford to buy me clothes
and [foreign word] made them all
without asking me once
what color I liked,
whether I wanted shorts,
a dress, nada right?
They came and you see this
picture of me in the bed,
I have 12 of them, one
for every year of my life,
right I'm sitting, it
was a staged photograph
and I was suppose to look
very grateful for the clothes,
I hope I look grateful there.
So I was thinking about my
abuelas, like family right?
And then I was thinking
about how this would look
in Merci's life and
then I thought
about how my mother always
wanted us to live all together.
It was her dream.
She had a cousin in Miami who
lived in three houses just
like this, these flat top houses
that the family had
connected one to the other
with little hallways and covered
roof ways, Julia lived in one,
Julie lived in the second
one and then Julieta,
the youngest one
lived in the third.
So three generations of a
family all in one compound.
I thought [foreign word],
right who would want to live
with relatives because they
all tell you what you do.
When to wash your hands,
what show you can watch,
you have to babysit a little
cousin, you know how it is.
So I thought this was crazy
but my mother thought
this was heaven.
So when I was writing Merci
Suarez Changes Gears I said you
know what she's going to live in
Florida and she's going to live
in three houses with
a big Badinski family.
And so I gave her abuela and
abuelo, the grandparents,
I gave her tia Inez with these
two psycho five year old twins
that are always getting
in trouble.
But then I said okay I also
need to give her a school life.
And someone at school
who really annoys her,
so I gave her Edna Santos.
Edna Santos who always says no
offense but, like no offense
but you don't spell well.
No offense but I
don't like your shirt.
No offense but your
eyeglasses are funny etcetera.
We all know an Edna Santos.
So I gave her Edna Santos.
But I had to give
her a bigger problem
and when I'm writing
books for kids I
like to tell them the truth
so I was thinking about some
of the problems that my
own family faced now.
And here was some of them.
The first I was remembering
abuelas sewing room
and that thing that use to scare
me when I slept over at night
because it has no head and legs.
And at night it cast big
shadows like a ghost.
But then I was thinking
of current life
and here's my husbands mother,
my kids call her Ola who was
in her 90's and had
come to live with us.
At the same time that my
mother who was very sick
and in her 80's had come
to live with us too.
At the same time that
tia Esa who was also
in her late 70's had
come to live with us,
are you counting
that's three old people
who came to live with us.
Okay. And they came to
live with us at a time
when I had teenage kids who did
band and brought friends over
and were starting to date.
And so [foreign word], abuela
and Esa and Ola were part
of our life but they also did
things that drove my kids crazy
like say things like this,
do you have a girlfriend?
Right? Oh boy.
And one time my son came
upstairs, that's him and Ola
and he looks so upset
I said [foreign word]
and he says Ola came out
to say goodnight to me.
I said so what and he goes
she was not wearing pants.
Very upsetting.
And so what ended
up happening is
that my kids stopped
bringing home, you see my son
and his friends there.
My kids stopped bringing
home friends and they started
to leave the table quick.
And I felt sad about
that and I knew
that they missed the
grandmothers that they remember
that brought them
Pokemon and Bay Blades
and a million stuffed animals.
And we were all trying to live
together and love each other
and understand all the
ways we were changing.
The way teenagers were changing,
the way we change in our 80's.
So I wrote that story because
eventually my kids did get
to the other side.
We did figure out how to
make that family work.
And so it was crazy and
people were butting in
and asking crazy questions
but there was a lot of love
in that family and that's
what I wanted to write
for Merci Suarez Changes Gears.
So it's a story that's funny,
that has annoying people,
that even has an
unfortunate eyebrow incident.
But it also has loss and the
way that we have to say goodbye
to the people who
matter the most to us.
This cover I just want to give
a shout out to Joseph Cepeda,
do you know the book
Esperanza Rising?
So Joe was the artist of that
book cover and I'm so honored
that he is the artist
of this one.
And the last thing I want
to say, because I know a lot
of you have iPhones is that
Merci Suarez has, her dream is
to get this bike right
and the first chapter
of the book and throughout.
I'm giving away a bike.
So if you go to this website you
can enter, it's a small essay
of why you want to win a bike
or you just post a picture
of yourself on this bike
and on September 11th
which is the official pub date,
we're going to pull a name
and if you are willing to
drive to Richmond Virginia
where I live, a mere hour
and 45 minutes to the south.
You could win a beautiful
mountain bike,
so check it out on that website.
And I think we have like five
minutes or so for questions,
so if you want to ask
me anything about Merci,
about writing, about
my crazy family,
now's the time, [foreign word].
Yes oh please come
to the microphones
if you have a question.
Nada, I have stunned you?
Okay then I am going
to, last call,
oop here comes someone,
thank you.
>> Oh I just love to talk
to you, I just didn't want
to hog it up so, I have a girl
scout troop and it's a mixture
of girls whose heritage
is Bolivian.
We have one girl who is from,
her parents are from Vietnam
and we have another family
they're from Afghanistan.
And I'm just sitting here
listening to you talk
about your culture
and how it blossoms
and thinking that's the
kind of things that I love
when they start talking and
comparing, usually in sort
of negative terms but.
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
You know how it is in their
homes and everything like that.
You know I think what's
really interesting to me is
that when you talk to kids from,
whose families comes from all
over the world, you find
a lot of similarities,
especially around
extended families.
Like this notion that your
grandparents live separate
from your parents, live separate
from cousins and things.
It's very unique to us here
but really typically we live
in extended families and
also like the hard things
of like explaining this
culture to people who are
of another culture like if
your grandparents see things
from a different perspective,
like that's really challenging.
But I do love to, I
just love to see that.
>> I just love the way you told
that story and I'm going to try
to tell that story to my girls.
>> Meg Medina: Well get the
recording, that could be easier.
Hello on this side.
>> Hello.
>> Meg Medina: Yes.
>> Where you ever bullied cause
of the clothes you
wear from your tia or?
>> Meg Medina: Say that again.
>> Where you ever, oh,
where you ever bullied cause
of your clothes?
>> Meg Medina: Was I ever
bullied because of my clothes?
>> Yeah.
>> Meg Medina: No cause my
grandmother was a really
good seamstress.
So I had some rocking clothes.
But I, she did a good
job but they weren't,
you know I would've
picked jeans, torn jeans
and sneakers and
things like that.
She had other ideas for me.
Yes?
>> Why did you think
it was a bad idea
for all your family
to live in one house?
>> Meg Medina: Because
in real life,
because I knew how my family was
and everybody had an opinion.
And everybody had,
everybody could raise me.
So it wasn't my parents, my
mother wasn't the only one
who could tell me to go to bed
or not eat this or do that,
everybody, so it was going
to be like having six
or seven moms and dads on me.
And that felt hard for me.
But in the end when I had
everybody living with us
when I was the mom
and I had kids,
I found that although it
was hard, it taught all
of us this way of being
generous to each other
and patient with each other.
There were some really
sad days together
and then there were also some
really happy days together.
And I wouldn't trade it, I
wouldn't do it differently.
Hi there.
>> When did you start
writing books?
>> Meg Medina: Well
unofficially in the third grade
when Mrs. Zuckerman said
that I was good at it
and I was really thrilled.
But I waited a long time,
I wrote all kinds of stuff
like advertisements and I wrote
in little newspapers
and things like that.
But the year I turned 40 I
decided it was now or never
and I quit my job and I
decided I was going to go home
and write a novel and
luckily for me it worked out.
Oh sorry.
>> Why did you want
to start writing?
>> Meg Medina: You
know my family,
I come from a family
of story tellers.
They, everything about them
when they were putting
away the groceries,
when we were driving somewhere,
when we were just sitting there
like pulling the rocks out of
the bowl of beans or whatever,
it always a story like,
huh I remember the time
that little boy got chased
in my village by the pig.
Oh I remember the time this
man ran away with so and so,
on and on, it was story
and story and story.
And my grandmother
was the best one
because she really
knew how to do drama.
Like she'd get to the part
that you were like on the edge
of your seat and
she'd say and you want
to know what happened next
and you'd be like, yes.
So she was wonderful
and so I learned early
on that stories knit
us together.
I learned early on that
stories sort of give you a sense
of like what happened
before you.
Right? And I learned
imagination through stories,
like just sitting
there listening
to it I could imagine Cuba,
I could imagine chickens,
I could imagine these big
juicy mango's, like all of it
and then it just
became part of how I am.
Hi.
[ Foreign Language ]
>> And my question was
I would like to know
if you are interested about
writing a book of children
or teenagers without relatives
or family here that come
from different countries and
how could be the life of them?
>> Meg Medina: Yeah.
Well I'm going to say this,
I think that there are
so many tragic stories
right now that we can tell
through the Latino lens.
Including children who
are here without parents,
who've been separated from
parents and in some way I did
that with the Tia Isa
Wants a Car if you know
that picture book of mine.
Her parents are elsewhere
and she's her with the Isa.
So would I be interested,
yes, but it's always the story
of the girl more than the issue.
I have to find the
connection to the young woman.
So I never say never,
it's possible.
And I think we have only
one more question I'm
down to two minutes.
Yes.
>> Okay so my question
is about Burn Baby Burn.
>> Meg Medina: Yes!
>> So what motivated you to
write about the son of Sam?
>> Meg Medina: Oh because
I was 14 the year that son
of Sam was murdering
girls in my neighborhood.
And that is a terrifying
experience.
And because I was wondering what
it's like for teenagers now,
who sort of have that
slow burn of fear in terms
of shooters and things
like that.
And I wanted to just take
a look at that history.
And right now my
timer is holding
up a very sweet sign
that says wrap it up.
So I'm going to wrap it up
and I'm so glad that you came,
I thought I wasn't going
to have anybody and it's
so nice to see your faces.
Gracias. Thanks, bye.